ces attaques se sont multipliées les
derniers jours sur sur plusieurs ponts
de Crimée le pan de sauna et le pont de
nichez ce sont deux plombs qui relient
la Crimée illégalement occupée depuis
2014 par la Russie à la partie occupée
du territoire de Helson donc dans le sud
de l'Ukraine alors la Russie affirme que
l'Ukraine aurait frappé avec des
missiles Storm Shadow donc c'est missile
fournis par le Royaume-Uni à l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine confirme pas cette utilisation
en revanche il est très important de
noter de noter que c'est frappes peuvent
affecter les forces russes dans le sud
de l'Ukraine pourquoi et bien parce que
la Crimée a servi de centre
d'approvisionnement de base arrière pour
les forces russes si les deux ponts qui
relient le territoire sud de l'Ukraine
et territoire occupés et bien ne sont
pas en état de fonctionner ça veut dire
que les lignes d'approvisionnement des
forces russes ne sont plus en état de
fonctionner et dans ce cas là et bien
les forces heureuses vont devoir
utiliser des routes le long de la mer
d'Azov donc plutôt vers l'est du pays
vers le sud-est du pays sauf que ces
routes là elles sont absolument à la
portée de l'artillerie ukrainienne donc
ça peut créer un avantage très
conséquent pour l'Ukraine qui est en
pleine contre-offensive